[Music]
She-Hulk nods to MCU trivia by laughing
in your face but wait that's not a bad
thing although Mark Ruffalo has become
the go-to version of the Hulk for modern
fans it's important to remember that the
Marvel Cinematic Universe says Green
Giant was first played by Fight Club and
The Grand Budapest Hotel star Edward
Norton The Incredible Hulk picks up with
Norton's Bruce Banner hiding from the
U.S military in Brazil while working on
a bottling plant to maintain a
stress-free life and prevent any Hulk
outs Norton not only starred in the film
but was also developing a story for a
sequel with Marvel which was ultimately
scrapped the actor opened up about what
he wanted to do with the character to
the New York Times magazine saying I
laid out a two film thing the origin and
then the idea of Hulk as a conscious
dreamer the guy who can handle the trip
as it turned out that wasn't what they
wanted but I had a great time doing it
ultimately Ruffalo replaced Norton going
into 2012's The Avengers and he's
arguably a much better fit for the MCU
as it is now it's hard to imagine the
American History X and Birdman star
going all in for the likes of Thor
Ragnarok and the Avengers movies this
all makes it rather surprising that it
took 12 years before a joke was made at
the actor swap She-Hulk attorney at law
episode 2 follows Jennifer Walters as
she tries to figure out how to navigate
her legal career now that she's become a
superhero celebrity she winds up leading
the Superhuman law division for a
prestigious firm and her first case is a
tricky one Jen is tasked with
representing Emile Blonsky AKA
abomination in his upcoming parole
hearing the villain from the Incredible
Hulk has been logged up in their super
max prison since the end of his fight
with Bruce making for the perfect time
for She-Hulk writers to throw in a
slight joke about recasting the big
green guy in She-Hulk episode 2 Jennifer
is conflicted about accepting the
position that's Goodman lever kurzberg
and Holloway Law Firm because she's
given an ultimatum she'll have a job
with them but only if she agrees to take
on Blonsky as a client if she refuses
she'll be back on the job hunt since
Abomination tried to kill the Hulk Jen
has some feelings about representing
Blonsky even though she's already made
up her mind she calls Bruce to get his
Blessing and he tells her it's totally
fine turns out Blonsky took the step of
writing Bruce a letter and even a haiku
many years ago and the two men have
since put their violence past behind
them that fight was so many years ago
I'm a completely different person now
literally the joke is low hanging fruits
but it works in fact it works so well
because Marvel already used it once
remember the actor Switcheroo for James
Roadie Rhodes between Iron Man 1 and
Iron Man 2. Terence Howard portrayed
Tony Stark's best friend in the first
film next time baby but he never got us
next time instead Iron Man 2 saw Don
chidor take up the role how they
acknowledge the shift back in the day
look it's me I'm here to deal with it he
is hoping Edward Norton took the joke
better than Terry parents how it did
[Music]